it's been ordinance OSHA cannabis
testing the new Skoda Octavia
stationwagon today near Hamburg the
Scout version may not look new but it is
sasha says we can see he's already
test-driven it and he's pretty satisfied
it's the scoping once it's on scoot is
on TV a scout station wagon will go on
the European market and late August it
isn't just out to impress like some cars
that look like off-road vehicles the
Scout has off-road technology and design
the cuff Tim's Sasha says the new Haldex
5 coupling distributes power to all four
of the Scouts wheels as needed the
Haldex 5 traction system makes the
Octavius Scout outstanding when offroad
power is always distributed optimally
among all the wheels so that the Scout
can climb steep slopes even if they are
not paid
the Scout can also handle steep downhill
rides
but Abeka facha says the car has no
special support going downhill so the
driver has to do the braking himself but
at least in this case that's no problem
above the headlights the body hasn't
changed as Skoda earns the Scout emblem
with its off-road capabilities
under the headlights and taillights the
transition to the bumpers has been made
even more angular
the wheel rims fit that pattern too
decoys Natasha says the biggest
difference is between the normal station
wagon version of the Octavia and the
Scout version are the large air intakes
in front and a skid plate the rear also
has a skid plate on top of that says
Sasha the Scout can pull up to two tons
for example a horse trailer
this towing power is great for vacations
- we tested the Scout with a most
powerful diesel engine one that puts out
135 kilowatts thanks to its direct shift
gearbox the Scout Sprint's from 0 to 100
km/h at 7.8 seconds the largest diesel
consumes exactly as much fuel as the
smallest 5.1 liters per 100 kilometers
Skoda is working to reduce fuel
consumption in our whatz inches
he will toll the cart Esther says the
new version is optimized fuel
consumption by up to 20% by means of
great energy recuperation and the
automatic start/stop function automatic
the check machine drives through small
patches of water in stride the underbody
is completely shielded protecting the
machinery from stones and branches the
brakes have additional protection to the
Scout has 33 millimeters more clearance
than the standard Octavius stationwagon
does easing travel on rocky roads and
steep inclines the interior is typical
Octavia and well-crafted the scouts logo
is found in various spots
the Scout combines a number of good
characteristics generous space more
safety on the road off-road capabilities
and very good towing power and yet its
needs at the fuel pump are modest and at
thirty two thousand six hundred fifty
euros in Germany with the most powerful
engine it's reasonably priced yet my
there's a saying that the cleaner of
colour looks after off-road duty the
better it was our test car is pretty mud
splattered our car tester had a great
time flowing through the countryside
with a Skoda Octavia Scout station wagon
so he recommends it for anyone who wants
a vehicle that can really go off-road